[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportages et d'expertise sur Public
Sénat 90 minutes pour donner du sens à
l'actualité vous proposez des clés de
compréhension des mutations de notre
société et voici le sommaire de ce 6
décembre la loi sur l'immigration la
réforme des retraites de textes sur
lesquels le gouvernement avance
aujourd'hui de réformes pour lesquelles
il aura besoin des voix des
parlementaires LR mais font-ils ce
cadeau à Emmanuel Macron comment
Elisabeth borne venu de la gauche
porte-t-elle ses lois qui penchent à
droite ce sera notre débat actu dans une
minute et puis dans trois quarts d'heure
c'est un débat de société que je vous
propose faut-il rendre l'uniforme
obligatoire à l'école
que c'est un bon outil de d'égalité
entre les enfants
que
ça a l'air pas mal d'être tous pareils
les vêtements les chaussures ce genre de
choses et c'est bien de leur apprendre
ça dès le primaire
une tenue scolaire pour lutter contre le
harcèlement pour défendre la laïcité
dise ce qui défendent cette idée les
autres parlent une fausse tradition
française et d'un projet qui masque des
réformes urgentes pour l'avenir de nos
enfants ne ratez pas l'analyse et la
confrontation de nos experts tout à
l'heure mais d'abord donc ce projet de
loi sur l'immigration présentée à
l'assemblée pour un premier débat sans
vote le contenu les réactions avec
Fabien reker
expulser davantage les personnes en
situation irrégulière tout en intégrant
mieux les travailleurs étrangers avec
son projet de loi sur l'immigration le
gouvernement tente un grand écart
accueillir ceux qui veulent s'intégrer
leur donner une vie administrative
normale qui puisse éduquer leurs enfants
dans des conditions acceptables dans la
République qui puisse aussi bien
comprendre que s'il travaille en France
s'il parle français ils seront intégrés
s'il commettent des actes délinquance
ils seront expulsés on veut ce qui
bossent on veut pas ce qui rapine
l'exécutif veut notamment rendre plus
efficace les obligations de quitter le
territoire français les fameuses
occultées F à ce jour la France en
exécute moins de 10%. le projet de loi
devrait réduire drastiquement les
recours possibles une fois qu'une
occupée F a été prononcée une politique
plus répressive déjà critiquée par la
gauche qui juge inapplicable un
durcissement des auqtf si l'asile est
refusé avant même tout recours en point
de via au prix TF donc obligation de
quitter le territoire français mais il y
a rien qui permet d'assurer va pouvoir
mieux les appliquer donc on aura le
droit plus répressif et en même temps on
n'a pas les moyens d'appliquer encore
mieux que ce qu'on fait maintenant donc
en fait je ne comprends pas la démarche
est-ce qu'il faut pas faire en fait un
vrai accueil ici des migrants pour se
dire comme ça on va arriver à les
intégrer et on n'aura pas autant de
critères et on n'aura pas les mêmes
problèmes mais le gouvernement veut
aussi tendre la main au travailleur sans
papier et promet de délivrer des titres
de séjour d'un en renouvelable aux
étrangers qui travaillent dans les
métiers en tension comme la restauration
les métiers de la propreté ou encore le
BTP c'est régularisation seront soumises
à des critères à prévenus Gérald
Darmanin comme l'âge l'ancienneté sur le
territoire ou même des quotas ce sera au
parlementaire de tranchées la droite
dénonce déjà un risque de régularisation
massive qu'on ne laisse pas croire à des
tas de personnes que demain elles seront
régularisées et à d'autres qu'elles
peuvent venir et qu'un jour ou l'autre
on les régularisera c'est ça l'enjeu
donc c'est de regarder les situations
vraiment particulières et à ce moment là
on peut effectivement apporter des
régularisations dans des cas précis de
métiers en tension de gens peut-être qui
sont sur le territoire depuis longtemps
mais en aucun cas une régularisation
massive ça c'est absolument à proscrire
le projet du gouvernement devrait
également mettre l'accent sur
l'apprentissage du français en
conditionnant l'obtention d'un titre de
séjour un examen de maîtrise de la
langue française il s'agit du 29e projet
de loi sur l'immigration depuis 1980
et c'est un débat 100% politique que je
vous propose pour démarrer ce sens
public on parlera des retraites des
cabinets de conseil dans un instant et
donc on commence sur ce projet de loi
immigration mes invités leur Salvin
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes directrice
générale de cantar public Jean-Sébastien
Ferjoux bonsoir et bienvenue fondateur
directeur d'Atlantico Pablo Pillot
Vivien bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
rédacteur en chef de la revue regard et
Guillaume Darré bonsoir c'est une vidéo
militarisme politique ou remplacez
Laetitia acupa pendant les deux semaines
elles sont bien arrivées
au mois de janvier et on lui fait un
coucou alors ça le vin en s'étend de
d'inflation de crises énergétique de
reprise de l'épidémie est-ce que
l'immigration reste une préoccupation
majeure des français où est-ce qu'elle
se situe d'ailleurs
l'immigration elle est depuis plusieurs
mois à peu près au dixième rang des
préoccupations des Français
alors effectivement c'est pas dans les
trois premières préoccupations comme
vous disiez les premières préoccupations
c'est la santé le pouvoir d'achat
l'inflation
et évidemment la hausse des prix donc le
sujet de l'immigration c'est quelque
chose qui depuis en revanche trois
quatre ans monte dans l'opinion il y a
trois quatre ans vous voyez c'était 10
points en dessous des préoccupations
d'aujourd'hui donc c'est quelque chose
qui bouge dans l'opinion et surtout qui
est très différent en fonction 1 de la
classe d'âge c'est à dire que plus on
est âgé plus et quelque chose qui
préoccupe les citoyens français de la
sympathie artisanale également vous avez
les sympathisants les républicains et
rassemblements rassemblement national
pour qui c'est la cinquième
préoccupation donc c'est pas la dixième
ça ça arrive à la cinquième et puis
l'agglomération parisienne aussi pour
qui c'est une préoccupation beaucoup
plus importante que la province donc
vous voyez qu'il y a aussi des des
disparités là dessus et moi ce qui m'a
marqué dans Dans les dernières opinions
qu'on dernières données d'opinion qu'on
a pu voir c'est c'est en dernier c'est
que une très grande majorité de Français
8 Français sur 10 considèrent qu'on ne
peut pas parler d'immigration de façon
de Rennes et alors ça c'est quand même
assez marquant c'est à dire à ce
sentiment que finalement quand on va
parler de ce sujet là il va y avoir des
tensions des oppositions et que c'est
difficile de d'avoir une opinion très
tranchée ou en tout cas d'en parler de
façon très sereine voilà c'est un sujet
effectivement complexe et Jean-Sébastien
Ferjoux c'est effectivement très
intéressant parce que on peut se dire
que le terrain est un peu miné pour le
gouvernement sur une thématique comme
cela pourtant il y a eu cette volonté la
première présentation elle est faite par
deux ministres par le ministre de
l'Intérieur et par le ministre du
Travail à cette espèce de dans même
temps macroniste qui veut s'appliquer à
la thématique de de l'immigration est-ce
que cette cette loi telle qu'elle est
proposée pour l'instant vous la trouvez
équilibré ou faussement équilibré
je crois qu'elle passe largement à côté
des véritables sujets mais ça me paraît
pas du tout à autre chose que deux
ministres la présence dans la mesure où
il y a le contrôle des flux migratoire
d'un côté et après il y a l'intégration
des immigrés soit qui arrive en France
soit de ceux qui sont déjà présents et
évidemment que ça concerne notamment
leur intégration sur le marché du
travail donc de ce point de vue là il
n'y a rien à redire mais les verrous
politiques juridiques intellectuelles
même aussi qui participent d'ailleurs du
fait que les Français ont l'impression
qu'on ne puisse pas avoir de débat
serein non je ne vois pas en quoi cette
loi va les lever aussi longtemps que la
France ne retrouvera pas en quelque
sorte sa souveraineté juridique mais
nous serons pris dans une hiérarchie des
normes qui fait que de toute façon il
est très difficile d'expulser et que
c'est très paradoxal l'immigration ça ne
relève pas à proprement parler d'Union
Européenne sauf que nous sommes dans un
espace de circulation commun donc chaque
état assez politique nationale chaque
état a sa vision nationale avec des
visions profondément différentes entre
l'est et l'ouest de l'Europe notamment
mais ensuite comme je vous le disais
c'est quand même l'espace Schengen donc
depuis longtemps qu'on reste de toute
façon dans cette pour le coup ça n'est
pas un entre deux ou alors un entre deux
chaises ou entre plusieurs chaises rien
ne pourra avancer et cette loi là ne
gère pas ce point-là sur un point précis
Pablo Piol Vivien le chef Thierry Marx
qui est devenu le président du principal
syndicat patronal de l'hôtellerie et
restauration il appelle à une
régularisation des salariés étrangers du
secteur vous dites quoi vous dites bravo
vous dites enfin oui ben je dis bravo et
d'ailleurs c'est à peu près ce que
propose le gouvernement enfin je veux
dire quand on écoute Olivier du soft et
Gérald Darmanin c'est ce qui propose moi
ce qui d'ailleurs j'y suis tout à fait
favorable comme une comme pratiquement
toute toute la gauche réunie il y a
juste un problème et vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que Gérald
Darmanin en fait il joue sur un double
tableau c'est à dire qu'il dit oui
effectivement ceux qui travaillent on va
les intégrer mais ceux qui en gros n'ont
pas de contrat de travail cela on va on
va les renvoyer ce qui est rapide
il contrevient à une directive qui avait
pourtant été donnée
des expulsions et on va virer en gros
tous ceux qui n'ont pas mais juste la
question à mon avis importante que pose
ce débat aujourd'hui c'est au fond
qu'est-ce qu'ils font de l'appartenance
à la France à la nation française et
Gérald Darmanin répond c'est le travail
moi je suis désolé mais je pense que
c'est une définition à très courte vue
très très réductrice en fait de ce
qu'est la France aujourd'hui il y a
plein de gens qui travaillent pas et qui
pourtant sont français il y a plein de
gens qui sont sur le territoire français
et qui sont immigrés par exemple parce
qu'ils ont des enfants français ou je ne
sais quoi et qui ont tout à fait
légitime il y a aussi le respect des
lois françaises Gérald Darmanin lui
était encore à l'Assemblée tout à
l'heure dernière déclaration à cette fin
d'après-midi trop de règles
spécifiquement françaises empêche
d'expulser les criminels étrangers
criminels étrangers présents sur notre
sol il dit nous vous proposerons dans ce
texte de loi de ne plus nous censurer de
laisser au juge le soin de mesurer si la
vie privée est familiale et le droit au
séjour sont compatibles avec des actes
de graves délinquance là il parle du
respect des lois françaises c'est pas
seulement la question de la valeur
travail j'entends tout en effet et le
problème et vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure dans votre introduction le
problème que cible Gérald Darmanin c'est
c'est juste c'est seulement 10% de qtf
qui sont qui vont jusqu'au bout en gros
qui aboutissent à une expulsion et il se
concentre là-dessus mais ce qui ne
comprend pas en fait c'est que si ces
occultés F ne vont pas jusqu'au bout
c'est parce que précisément il y a des
règles de droit des recours il y a des
discussions en fait entre les
différentes juridictions qui font en
train de nous dire quelque chose
mais bonne chance à lui parce que genre
le problème c'est que on a aussi signé
des chartes on est on est à l'ONU on est
à la à la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme et que notre appartenance à ce
genre de juridiction fait que on peut
pas faire n'importe quoi avec le droit
genre Sébastien ça vous intéresse mais
ça vous intéressement quand il s'agit de
libre-échange ou de concurrence comme
quoi c'est toujours chacun voit midi à
sa porte en matière de droit européen ou
hiérarchie des normes mais c'est
exactement ce que je vous disais aussi
longtemps que de toute façon on n'aura
pas géré ce problème cette problématique
de souveraineté juridique de la France
rien pourra avancer mais je crois que
géraldar maintenant tombe dans un piège
c'est un piège intellectuel de dire il
faut expulser les étrangers en situation
irrégulières et criminels parce que de
toute façon derrière ça il y a une
question de fond une question théorique
que personne ne pourra éviter encore
moins quand on regarde les défis
démographiques notamment en Afrique la
population africaine devrait être
multipliée au moins par trois d'ici la
fin du siècle dernier c'est jusqu'où
jusqu'où l'Europe alors la France parce
que nous sommes français peut-être
accueillir parce qu'on peut se poser la
question qu'est-ce que c'est quatre
Français ou sommes capables de leur
donner un travail mais cette question là
au moins d'un point de vue théorique et
c'est là-dessus aussi où je pense et ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure que les
français se sentent dépossédés de leur
débat par le type d'argument que vient
de nous livrer
son culturel ça ça rejoint cette
question là à quel
pointure
française ça concerne la France mais ça
concerne je pense toutes les démocraties
il ne peut pas y avoir de liberté sans
frontière et il ne peut pas y avoir de
liberté sans responsabilité et adhésion
à un socle de valeurs communes s'il n'y
a pas de s'il n'y a pas de frontière
vous voyez bien que c'est un
environnement de communauté règne la loi
du plus fort et ou de la communauté la
plus agressive ou la plus forte et même
chose si vous avez des gens qui
s'installent là uniquement parce qu'on
considère qu'ils sont tous
interchangeables et finalement ils ont
qu'à travailler dans des usines pour des
mauvaises salaires parce que on a quand
même appliqué le modèle asiatique sur
notre propre territoire vous voyez bien
que ces questions là il faudra les
tranchées de toute façon réduire la
question à la question de la délinquance
et à mon avis c'est ce que dit l'ancien
patron de la DGSE dans un dans une
expression qu'il a fait je crois devant
l'Amicale gaulliste qui a été reprise
aujourd'hui et publiée par nos confrères
du Figaro dans lequel il explique tout
cette démarche mais derrière le débat on
sent qu'il y a quand vous échangez avec
l'entourage de Gérard Darmanin il y a
aussi la dimension politique d'essayer
de lutter dit-il en tout cas c'est c'est
ce qu'il revendique comme une forme
d'impuissance du pouvoir politique il
dit en gros y compris du côté du
président de la République ce qu'on
reproche à tous les chefs d'état depuis
30 ans c'est de donner le sentiment que
y compris le président de la République
ne peut plus rien faire et n'agit plus
sur rien c'est notamment le discours de
Marine Le Pen encore absolument ou
aujourd'hui par exemple de le ren quand
on sait qu'il travaille sur son projet
futur projet présidentiel c'est quelque
chose qu'il veut porter donc derrière le
projet et derrière les mots extrêmement
forts Gérald Darmanin il y a aussi cette
volonté de dire regardez on peut encore
faire bouger les choses il y a aussi une
volonté d'Emmanuel Macron de ne pas
apparaître ou en tout cas d'essayer de
convaincre les gens qu'il n'a pas la
naïveté qu'on peut lui prétendre sur
cette question là parce que c'est quand
même l'un des points faibles du chef de
l'État depuis le début de ce premier
mandat mais c'est vrai quand on regarde
dans le détail de ce texte là on l'a
entendu dans la majorité sénatoriale ici
et chez les républicains à la à
l'Assemblée nationale l'un des points de
faiblesse c'est quand même le notamment
le la volonté d'inscription au fichiers
des personnes recherchées on sait que
c'est plus un élément statistique qu'un
élément de renvoi des personnes sur leur
territoire donc là il y aura
effectivement un point quoi que devra
éclaircir Gérald darmann alors on cesse
de verser des allocations à des gens qui
sont sous le coup de qtf voir qui ont
été expulsés il avait posé aussi on
n'est pas capable de le vérifier ce que
vous nous dites non parce que
l'administration le refuse Nathalie
Goulet laissé maîtrise
pour la première fois cette année on
propose enfin de dire que si des
allocations soient versées qu'elles le
soient sur des comptes bancaires
français genre jusqu'à présent je
voudrais qu'on écoute pardon nous
interrompre la première ministre qui
était à l'Assemblée en cette fin
d'après-midi qui est un peu posé le
cadre finalement et là aussi on est dans
un dans un équilibre en tout cas affiché
Elisabeth borne oui je souhaite que le
droit et nos frontières soient respectés
oui je souhaite des éloignements rapides
et efficaces des personnes en situation
irrégulière mais non on ne peut pas
prétendre que les choses soient simples
comme si nous pouvions nous affranchir
de l'indispensable coopération des pays
d'origine et des règles de l'État de
droit de l'autre côté certains appellent
à des opérations de régularisation
massive je le dis aussi clairement il
n'en n'est pas question nous ne créerons
pas de telles précédents qui ne
régleraient pas les difficultés des
personnes concernées qui donneraient des
arguments au passeur et qui ne ni
accepté ni acceptable par les Français
leur seul vin cette loi c'est un test
pour Elisabeth borne pour son
gouvernement sa capacité à
mobiliser tout tout partie des députés
et des parlementaires LR mais la
question si je rejoins ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure c'est les
parlementaires et l'air vont-ils suivre
leur propre sympathisants effectivement
mais je crois que Elisabeth borne elle
essaie de composer avec cette assemblée
déjà depuis plusieurs mois et on voit
effectivement à quel point c'est
difficile et aussi à quel point dans
l'opinion c'est perçu de façon pas très
positive parce que ce qu'attendait les
Français dans cette nouvelle Assemblée
c'est justement beaucoup plus de
compromis de discussions de d'échanges
etc et c'est plutôt il faut être minima
2 pour arriver à un compromis
qui sont les responsables ils peuvent
être des deux côtés certainement
partager mais donc cette loi
effectivement en tout cas là telle
qu'elle est lancée c'est un peu un coup
d'essai ils disent voilà il y aura pas
de vote aujourd'hui il y aura pas tout
de suite on va voir comment réagit
l'opinion ce qui est sûr et certain
c'est que on est sur du en même temps
qui ne convainc pas forcément l'opinion
aujourd'hui sur ce sujet là je crois que
l'opinion elle a une elle a justement
une vision très claire des choses elle
est justement on le disait focalisée sur
le pouvoir d'achat c'est quelque chose
qui l'a préoccupe beaucoup c'est une
opinion française aussi qui a souffert
ces dernières années par un certain
nombre de crises la France n'est pas la
seule effectivement mais enfin bon elle
a été traumatisée par un certain nombre
d'événements et donc la question se pose
de savoir et c'est un peu la question
numéro 1 des Français c'est est-ce que
on est encore capable d'accueillir dans
de bonnes conditions toutes les
personnes qui qui le demandent et ça on
a vraiment du mal en tout cas quand on
les écoute les Français on a du mal à
avoir ce débat encore une fois de façon
sereine puisque on est tout de suite
comment dire contrebalancer par
effectivement cet élan un peu émotionnel
de solidarité évidemment de pays de
droits de etc voilà c'est un sujet
compliqué et justement je parle
d'émotion très très émotionnelle et qui
qui est complexe aussi pour les Français
appréhender alors il y a une voix que je
trouve intéressante à entendre dans un
débat sur l'immigration c'est celle de
Benoît Hamon l'ancien candidat à la
présidentielle qui est devenu
directeur général d'une ONG une
internationale qui s'appelle Singa qui
travaille justement à l'intégration des
réfugiés et des immigrés dans le monde
du travail il était sur France Info ce
matin Benoît Hamon écouter tous les pays
qui ont décidé de fermer leurs
frontières aux migration non pas empêché
les migrations de changer d'échelle
c'est valable pour la France c'est
valable pour le continent européen donc
construire une loi avec l'objectif de
renvoyer le maximum de gens ou de faire
entrer le minimum de gens est à nos yeux
un non-sens alors est-ce que c'est un
non-sens je vais vous entendre les uns
et les autres Pablo piovi bien est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord et Benoit je suis
totalement d'accord avec Benoît Hamon et
il dit que ça s'applique au contenu
européen mais pas uniquement quand vous
regardez la la courbe oui des entrées
illégales sur le territoire
globalement elle subit des variations
mais ces variations sont justifiées par
ce qui se passe dans les pays d'origine
notamment les pays latino-américains si
vous avez des grands chamboulements dans
ces pays alors vous avez beaucoup de
gens qui vont vouloir aller aux
États-Unis et ça ne ça ne change pas en
vrai véritablement les politiques qui
sont menées à la frontière
américano mexicaine vous dites ça dépend
pas des pays d'accueil de la politique
des pays d'accueil ça dépend de la
situation économique des pays d'origine
quand vous mettez un mur ou quand vous
mettez des snipers etc qu'est-ce que
vous allez faire vous allez générer de
la souffrance voir des morts sur cette
frontière mais globalement les gens vont
quand même traverser s'ils ont envie de
traverser regardez nous en auriez pas la
théorie de l'appel d'air parce que c'est
une vraie théorie dans la matière quant
à quand un état annonce une politique
plus en matière d'immigration il y a un
appel théorie elle est aussi vrai et
aussi justifier que celle du Grand
remplacement regardez ce qui nous sépare
en fait du continent africain c'est la
mer Méditerranée c'est à dire que vous
avez pas de mur plus efficace que genre
une mère de cette taille là pour autant
et malgré la souffrance et les morts en
fait que ça génère les gens les
Africains tentent le le passage au prix
et parfois il paye au prix de leur vie
ou de ou de leurs enfants donc ça veut
dire que on ne peut pas arrêter et quand
moi je suis pas d'accord avec ce que dit
Jean-Sébastien la question de la
frontière aujourd'hui il faut
l'envisager de façon poreuse certes on
doit avoir une souveraineté à
l'intérieur de ses frontières et il faut
réfléchir à comment est-ce qu'elle
s'exerce qu'est-ce que c'est que
qu'est-ce qui fait l'unité d'une société
etc en revanche vouloir mettre des murs
et empêcher les gens de se déplacer sur
un sur un territoire qui est aussi grand
que la terre je pense que vraiment c'est
un vœu pieux alors donc vous dites
régularisation massive mais bien sûr il
faut trouver les moyens de les intégrer
pas forcément leur donner la
nationalisation la nationalité française
mais au moins de leur permettre de
rester sur le territoire français parce
que on les envoie ils reviennent ça
passe notamment par le travail en y
revient Jean-Sébastien Fargeot non mais
c'est faux quand tu regardes aux
États-Unis Donald Trump n'a pas
construit son mur ou dans la construire
une partie minime et pour autant la
présence de l'argent les flux
migratoires ce sont beaucoup réduits au
point d'ailleurs que certains suits
américains ont commencé à venir vers
l'Europe parce qu'ils pouvaient
bénéficier pour certains de passeports
espagnols quand jobiden est arrivé la
même politique migratoire la même est
exactement en vigueur c'est en continu à
séparer les mineurs de leurs parents etc
d'ailleurs ce qui se faisait déjà du
temps de Barack Obama aussi personne ne
sont les nouvelles à l'époque les flux
migratoires ont remonté en flèche c'est
le signal qui est envoyé on l'a vu avec
l'Australie un exemple peut-être moins
connu l'équateur l'équateur était dirigé
par un président proche justement de
l'idéologie chère à Jean-Luc Mélenchon
que s'est-il passé en Équateur dans la
Constitution équatorienne on a inscrit
le fait que tous les étrangers les
Colombiens les venezuelins notamment qui
fuyaient leur pays en masse pour
différentes raisons avait vocation être
traité comme les Équatoriens ben sauf
qu'au bout de trois ans ça a explosé que
les Équatoriens disent ça n'est pas
possible et pourtant il y a une
continuité culturelle qui existe entre
le Venezuela la Colombie et l'Équateur
donc ça n'existe pas l'Australie je vous
le disais même chose l'Australie a
envoyé un signal très net et
l'immigrations ont beaucoup baissé ça
n'arrive jamais à zéro quant à l'idée
que par la Méditerranée mais c'est une
Judée de l'esprit la première porte
d'entrée en France c'est Roissy c'est
pas compliqué c'est par les aéroports
qui arrivent les étrangers parce que
bien souvent ils arrivent sur des
visages sur des visas ensuite ils
ouvrent pas ou alors avec des papiers
falsifiés le sujet de toute façon c'est
pas celui de la frontière en soi c'est
celui du signal qui est envoyé vous
voyez bien que la Chine
mais pas un signal attention
où est-ce qu'il y a eu le plus de
croissance économique sur les 30
dernières années en Asie du Sud-Est
est-ce que vous voyez des migrants qui
sont partis en masse installer en Chine
non pourquoi parce que le modèle chinois
ne leur fait pas envie ce qui attire et
cela dit bien pour une Europe qui doute
beaucoup d'elle-même c'est notre modèle
mais on voit bien que la ça ne peut pas
les flux migratoires sont forcément
calqué sur l'attractivité sur le signal
qui est envoyé le Danemark envoyer des
signaux extrêmement clairs qui ne
voulaient plus de migrants et ben ça a
beaucoup réduit des flux vers le
Danemark un dernier mot Guillaume la
limite une vision disons généreuse de la
politique d'immigration c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
à Paris l'hiver ça n'est pas une vision
c'est qu'aujourd'hui la gestion qui
devrait se faire des frontières au
niveau européen ne se fait pas ou qu'en
tout cas les pays qui devraient qui ont
un charge cette gestion des frontières
extérieures oui mais
il faut réfléchir ne sont pas capables
de la gérer en fait parce qu'on ne les
aide pas non plus mais ça veut dire quoi
gérer une frontière ça veut dire quoi
donner de l'argent en fait à Erdogan
pour qu'il fasse des camps des camps
d'immigrés sur le territoire turc moi je
suis désolé mais c'est pas ce que je
souhaite en fait pour l'Europe je n'ai
pas envie qu'on mène ce type de
politique j'ai pas envie non plus qu'on
demande au Bulgarie en fait de
construire ce type de camp le Pablo
est-ce que vous irez chercher dans ce
cas-là des migrants africains que les
Sud-Africains rejettent parce que des
mouvements anti migrants et beaucoup
plus dur que tout ce qu'on peut
connaître en Europe il y en a en Afrique
il y en a à Soweto notamment qui se sont
créés et ce que vous irez chercher les
gens qui sont parce que vous considère
vous voyez bien qu'à un moment
ça va peut-être conclu sur ce thème
ensuite on va parler retraite est-ce que
tiens l'argument de la régularisation
massive est-ce que c'est audible par
l'opinion alors c'est c'est une question
très générale ou par une partie
suffisamment large de l'opinion
française c'est plutôt l'Occident est
plutôt opposé à toute régularisation
massive et même de façon assez forte il
souhaite beaucoup plus de contrôle et de
dureté dans durcissement des règles dans
ce dans ce domaine-là mais juste moi je
voudrais revenir sur justement la
régularisation pour notamment les
travailleurs étrangers etc le risque
aussi et ça l'opinion le le voit bien
c'est que ce soit un moyen pour les
chefs d'entreprise pour les
restaurateurs etc de baisser les niveaux
de salaire alors même qu'il y a quand
même un vrai sujet sur ces métiers en
commission aujourd'hui nous ouvriers
agricoles ou les serveurs regardez
l'Angleterre continuait à attirer parce
que effectivement les gens sont sous
payés le droit du travail n'est pas
respecté aujourd'hui c'est aussi un
moyen quand la personne que vous
employez sans papier d'en profiter
encore c'est la même chose avec le droit
d'asile le droit d'asile est une réalité
et évidemment que c'est l'honneur des
démocraties de respecter le droit
d'asile par c'est devenu une filière de
migration dont on détourne l'esprit
voilà c'est la même chose notamment les
Français considèrent effectivement que
le fait est bien de régulariser sur ce
sur cette thématique là de l'emploi et
notamment de l'emploi en tension et bien
c'est un moyen pour les entreprises et
pour les restaurateurs notamment de
baisser les salaires voilà c'est ce que
l'opinion pense c'est intéressant à
avoir en tête merci de de cette
précision le deuxième thème de notre
débat les retraites Guillaume Darré vous
allez poser les les enjeux pourquoi
Emmanuel Macron est-il aussi attaché à
cette réforme des retraites parce que
Thomas parle sous votre contrôle dans
l'imaginaire politique collectif
s'attaquer aux retraites c'est ce qui
vous permet d'accrocher le badge de
réformateur quand on est président
d'ailleurs quand on regarde l'histoire
tous les présidents ont fait leur
réforme des retraites sauf Emmanuel
Macron et il est bien décidé à ne pas le
à ne pas le rester
d'autant plus qu'on sait que depuis le
début de ce second mandat il y a un
sentiment un peu tâtonnement on ne sait
pas vraiment où il veut aller et donc il
y a pas question pour lui d'apparaître
comme un président de la quatrième qui
serait là que pour inaugurer les crises
anthem il veut la faire aussi parce que
rappelez-vous il a déjà renoncé il y a
une réforme des retraites au début de
son premier mandat il y avait cette
réforme dite par point qu'il jugeait
plus juste qui a été abandonné parce que
trop complexe trop incompréhensible
suspendu aussi parce qu'on était au
moment où toutes les réformes en cours
avaient été suspendues au moment de la
pandémie des retraites de la pandémie du
covid
là dessus ça intéresse
et donc il est pas question pour lui de
renoncer une deuxième fois et puis quand
vous parlez à son entourage il vous
explique aussi que c'est une façon de
répondre en quelque sorte aux critiques
de ceux qui l'accusent bien de ne pas
avoir réduit la dépense publique ce qui
est vrai et que donc apparaître comme
celui qui aura rétabli ou en tout cas
maintenu à l'équilibre le régime des
retraites ça lui permettra finalement de
revendiquer une forme de sérieux
budgétaire alors on le sait c'est pas
populaire faire comment compte-t-il
faire adopter cette réforme alors là
c'est terminé en même temps clairement
ils assument comme sur cette question de
l'immigration la volonté de s'appuyer
sur le groupe des Républicains avec un
ministre qui me disait la semaine
dernière ce sera quand même compliqué
justement pour ces députés de droite de
s'opposer un texte qui ne sera pas loin
de celui qui avait été porté par Valérie
Pécresse et on a le sentiment quand on
échange avec plusieurs membres du
gouvernement qui a davantage justement
une volonté finalement et bien de
contrer la possible
finalement révolte sociale plus que la
révolte politique la révolte politique
on voit à peu près qui va voter le
contre qui va voter pour cette réforme
en revanche la vraie crainte des
parlementaires et des ministres c'est
qu'il y a une forme
d'incendie sociale qui prennent au début
de l'année prochaine y compris avec
peut-être d'éventuels coupures
d'électricité dans certaines villes
françaises c'est ce que me disait ce
midi un parlementaire ce serait
évidemment extrêmement compliqué à gérer
donc l'obsession aujourd'hui des
ministres c'est d'essayer de convaincre
les Français et l'opinion que la réforme
que ce gouvernement porte est une
réforme juge c'était le cas par exemple
d'Olivier Véran ce ça sur France 2
tout le monde n'aura pas à travailler
jusqu'à 65 ans il y aura des si vous
commencez à travailler tôt aujourd'hui
vous partez plutôt demain ce sera pareil
on fait extrêmement attention aux gens
qu'on débarque on fait attention aux
femmes aux carrières hachées et on veut
un juste partitions
de l'effort alors vous me l'avez dit
chaque président a eu sa réforme des
retraites on peut avoir un peu de mal à
comprendre pourquoi ça revient comme ça
régulièrement sur le tapis la question
d'une réforme des retrait l'idéal ce
serait de la régler pour faire une bonne
fois pour toute mais c'est compliqué
parce qu'évidemment par définition la
situation économique Thomas et l'évolue
et donc l'équilibre du système des
retraites également et donc il faut en
permanence souvent le réajuster et puis
c'est compliqué parce que c'est pas
qu'une question économique ceci une
question éminemment politique et
finalement le choix de repousser l'âge
de départ à la retraite ou au contraire
de le maintenir voire de le réduire et
donc de laisser davantage de temps
finalement à une retraite à un moment où
on pourrait profiter de ses proches
c'est un choix de société et puis ça
peut être remise en cause finalement à
chaque fois que la majorité politique
échange dans notre pays alors on va
commencer par revenir vers leur salade
sur l'opinion parce qu'effectivement ça
fait plusieurs mois bon on l'appelle
Emmanuel Macron a été élu peut-être que
la seule proposition que l'opinion a
retenu de sa campagne c'est de passer
l'âge de la retraite à 65 ans bref
ensuite il obtient pas la mâchorité à
l'Assemblée toute l'histoire mais il y a
quoi il y a une constante de l'opinion
dans son opposition à un prolongement de
l'âge de la retraite alors ce qu'on voit
c'est que c'est quand même un peu moins
crispé qu'il y a un an il y a un an dans
l'opinion quand on parlait de potentiel
réforme des retraites avant l'élection
présidentielle l'opinion bondissait en
disant mais attendez c'est vraiment pas
loin c'est pas du tout la priorité
on n'est pas du tout sur ces sujets là
donc là pour le coup il y avait un vrai
risque de soulever de soulèvement de la
population
extrêmement fort là c'est je dirais que
c'est un peu moins le cas déjà parce que
l'opinion elle est un peu préparée
effectivement par la campagne
présidentielle on a beaucoup entendu
parler parce que aussi visiblement
Emmanuel Macron il a décidé d'A donner
sa grande réforme des retraites qui
était cette réforme à point qui allait
vraiment bouleverser tout le tout le
système ce à quoi d'ailleurs été plutôt
attaché aux électeurs d'Emmanuel Macron
Emmanuel Macron ils étaient aussi ils
ont aussi voté pour lui pour ça
notamment ceux que les électeurs les
plus à droite et les plus âgés et puis
aussi parce que quelque part cette
réforme et je crois que ça c'est un
argument qui est plutôt positif elle se
présente comme une réforme de justice et
d'équité et ça les Français sont
particulièrement sensibles aujourd'hui à
ces sujets là et à remettre davantage
d'équité au sein de la société le fait
de le présenter de cette façon là
effectivement c'est quelque chose de
positif en revanche
un autre point qui qui n'est pas encore
complètement claire et vous le disiez
tout à l'heure c'est l'objectif de de la
réforme là pour le moment les Français
sont un petit peu dans le brouillard
quoi pourquoi effectivement on réforme
et quelle est l'urgence à réformer
aujourd'hui il y a aucun consensus
là-dessus aucun consensus sur le fait
qu'effectivement effectivement il est
absolument
urgent de réformer et peut-être dernier
point et c'est aussi pour cela
certainement qu'on ne voit pas encore de
crispation sur ces sujets là c'est que
on ne touche pas pouvoir d'achat des
Français encore une fois c'est la
préoccupation vraiment principale les
Français sont tous focalisés là-dessus
et cette réforme a priori ne prévoit pas
alors au contraire à part sur le minimum
retraite mais en tout cas ne prévoit pas
de baisse des pensions et c'est là
dessus surtout que les Français la
mobilisation sociale la capacité des
syndicats à mobiliser dans quelques
semaines mais sur le fond de la réforme
j'en sais bastien-ferjou est-ce que vous
dites voilà elle nous est finalement
imposé par la pyramide des âges le fait
que beaucoup de nos voisins européens
travaillent déjà
plus plus longtemps est-ce que vous
comprenez finalement la philosophie ou
la logique de cette réforme la logique
de fond le fait que oui la démographie
évolue et que ça puisse justifier qu'on
travaille un âge plus avancé pas
forcément donc ce qu'on commençait très
jeune mais si on raisonne en moyenne oui
moi ça je le comprends parfaitement ce
que je ne comprends pas c'est mais tout
ce que vous venez d'expliquer finalement
en disant c'est juste du signal Emmanuel
Macron veut dire qu'il est réformateur
il veut accrocher ça à sa veste il n'y a
pas de justification autre moi ce que je
vois c'est qu'il y a 1100 milliards de
dépenses publiques chaque année dans ce
pays que la réforme des retraites on
nous dit ça vise à économiser 8 à 9
milliards alors ce sont pas les mêmes
comptes en théorie mais enfin on voit
bien que l'État d'ailleurs on le voit ce
qui est ce qu'il est en train d'essayer
de faire avec l'agir et l'Arco de
récupérer ce qui est bien géré par des
partenaires sociaux pour le remettre
dans le budget de l'État qui lui est mal
géré mais faire 4 ou 5 enfin 8 ou 9
milliards qui seront à l'arrivée 4 ou 5
milliards parce que c'est toujours comme
ça qu'on veut regarder les réformes
précédentes il y a un objectif qui est
affiché puis après il y a la réalité en
général entre les deux il y a une
mobilisation la CGT ou d'autres ont
obtenu que des catégories privées déjà
bien protégées soit encore plus protégée
donc ça fait moins d'économies mais quel
est le sens d'économiser 4 ou 5
milliards quand l'État est incapable ou
la puissance publique au sens large ça
dépasse l'état d'ailleurs c'est aussi
les collectivités territoriales etc est
incapable de montrer qu'elle fait des
économies premier point et de deux est
incapable de montrer qu'elle se
préoccupe du dernier levier sur lequel
on peut jouer à savoir le niveau
d'emploi total dans le pays parce que il
n'y a aucune politique économique
cohérente et la question de l'emploi des
seniors avant de s'attaquer à la réforme
emploi des seigneurs il y a la question
de l'emploi tout court vous voyez bien
que la France structurellement un niveau
d'emploi qui est beaucoup plus faible
que dans la plupart des pays des pays
voisins je parle pas juste du niveau de
chômage je vous parle du niveau d'emploi
sur le nombre de gens qui dans le pays
ont effectivement un emploi ça à avoir
avec la manière dont on gère le contexte
macroéconomique mais là encore ça serait
bouleversé certaines certitudes de
Monsieur Macron puisque ça à avoir avec
la politique monétaire ça avoir avec la
manière dont l'euro est structuré et ça
ce sont des débats fondamentaux donc à
ouvrir de nouveaux fronts dans une
société qui est privilégiée finalement
c'est comme pour le covid on le voit
quand l'État ne sait pas quoi faire ce
sont les Français la variable
d'ajustement alors moi je trouve
parfaitement cohérent comme je vous le
disais que chacun puisse être amené à
faire des efforts mais pas quand ce sont
toujours les mêmes qui font des efforts
et que la puissance publique en face
montre qu'elle est absolument incapable
d'en faire alors vendredi dernier alors
que Elisabeth borne recevait les
syndicats le ministre du Travail nous a
en quelque sorte annoncé le calendrier
Olivier du soft nous avons rappelé que
la réforme sera présentée par le
gouvernement par les chefs du
gouvernement et moi-même autour du 15
décembre soit dans Noël comme nous
l'avons dit à l'automne pour un examen
pendant l'été en empreinte pendant
l'hiver pardonnez-moi et une mise en
œuvre dès le début de l'été 2023 pour
les premières mesures de la réforme des
retraites et donc c'est cet échange que
nous avons eu pour faire un point
d'étape tout simplement sur la route en
somme de ce travail j'ai l'impression
qu'il qu'il annonce les futurs journées
de rêver de manifestation et les galères
qui qui vont avec puisque le
gouvernement a déjà réussi avec cette
annonce un exploit recréer l'Union
syndicale CFDT cgtfo cfe-cgcftc une SA
solidaire et fessée ont publié ce
communiqué que l'on peut voir qu'annonce
donc une mobilisation unitaire je les
cite si le gouvernement demeure arc
goûter sur son projet de réforme des
de retraite Pablo piovillien en ce
moment il y a des il faut toujours avoir
ça en tête il y a des élections
professionnelles dans la fonction
publique ça va être jusqu'au 8 décembre
de mémoire la CFDT espère passer devant
la CGT ce qui serait historique est-ce
que le gouvernement peut espérer trouver
à Laurent Berger un peu plus conciliant
après ce scrutin si on essaye de
d'analyser les postures syndicales ou
alors ce qu'on contrarait on est vers
une vers une mobilisation très forte
d'après vous ah non enfin je veux dire
Laurent Berger il est assez clair depuis
le début il est contre
l'allongement de l'âge de départ à la
retraite et contre l'allongement des
annuités donc je pense pas que ça change
grand chose de ce qui va se passer le 8
décembre et les rapports de force juste
revenir sur ce que vous avez dit moi je
suis complètement d'accord avec les
enjeux que vous avez que vous avez mise
en avant Guillaume c'est vrai que en
fait il y a deux types d'enjeux c'est
est-ce que c'est l'équilibre du du
système de retraite où là on a un peu
l'impression que c'est un jeu où en gros
vous avez le gouvernement et les
oppositions qui disent mais si si le
d'orientation des retraites a dit que et
puis les autres les oppositions qui
disent exactement le contraire en citant
aussi le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites donc c'est quand même tout
trouvé exactement son contraire et donc
du coup tout le monde utilise ses
arguments donc je crois que l'enjeu
n'est pas l'enjeu véritable n'est pas là
l'enjeu il est comme vous avez dit
Guillaume c'est de réduire la dépense
publique c'est ça comme vous l'avez dit
aussi Jean-Sébastien c'est de réduire la
dépense publique et là effectivement
c'est un problème politique après il y a
le prime institutionnel qui a derrière
et vous citiez les syndicats c'est que
aujourd'hui vous avez une unité
syndicale contre ce projet de réforme
des retraites mais vous avez aussi une
opinion qui est contre la réforme des
retraites or il s'agissait et c'est un
gros problème institutionnel à mon sens
et démocratique il s'agissait de la
seule comme vous l'avez dit la seule
mesure identifier d'Emmanuel Macron donc
c'est légitime en fait qu'il souhaite
que ça aille jusqu'au bout puisqu'il
considéré qu'il a été élu pour ça
exactement et je vais pas remettre en
question son élection et là et la
légitimité de son premier et deuxième
tour c'est tout à fait juste c'est tout
à fait juste donc il y a eu des émotions
pas mal de tête entre le premier le
deuxième enfin là on a on a un problème
en fait faire entendre du fonctionnement
de notre démocratie c'est à dire que en
même temps on est là bon bah tous les
syndicats sont contre les syndicats et
les syndicats je le rappelle sont des
partenaires sociaux dans le cadre du
pilotage de la sécurité sociale et aussi
du coup de la question des retraites
s'ils sont tous contre si vous avez la
population qui est majoritairement
contre comment comment est-ce qu'on fait
dans un pays comme la France pour aller
jusqu'au bout alors même que c'est pour
ça qu'on a eu lieu Emmanuel Macron elle
est à un dernier mot très rapidement
comptable c'est une logique qui résonne
en statique parce que c'est ce qui
explique les différences dans les
hypothèses du corps c'est à dire que
tout bouge en même temps vous lisez la
démographie bouge la croissance bouge le
nombre de employés dans le pays bougent
et il y a un dernier élément qu'on
oublie souvent quand même quand on fait
le bilan à la fin des réformes c'est
combien ça coûte les mouvements sociaux
parce que quand vous regardiez le
premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
comptez il faudrait le compter
sérieusement combien de points de PIB ça
a compté à la France les mobilisations
alors il est pas responsable à lui seul
ce que je veux juste vous dire c'est que
dans l'arbitrage
c'est l'immobilisme absolu c'est à dire
qu'on fera plus jamais une réforme qui
risque de de
sauf à ce que je vous disais une partie
de l'opinion oui mais il faut quand même
prendre en compte le fait que ça a coûté
très cher la France il y a beaucoup de
commerces qui ont fermé beaucoup de
restaurateurs qui ont fermé et là vous
avez vu comme moi que les failli de
commerce sont en train d'exploser
notamment à regarder tous les comptes
notamment
je pense que c'est pas mal
ça n'est pas précisément il ne faut pas
être que comptable il faut embarquer les
gens dans la réforme c'est montrer qu'on
est capable de faire des effets un peu
moins de dérailleur 10 minutes et je
voudrais qu'on garde du temps même moins
de sa huit pour ce dernier thème dans
notre débat le dossier des cabinets de
conseils le gouvernement affirme avoir
tenu compte des recommandations du Sénat
écoutez tiens le ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique Stanislas Guerini il le
rappelait sur notre antenne le 18
octobre
j'ai envie je crois comme les sénatrices
et les sénateurs qui ont travaillé dans
cette commission d'enquête de renforcer
l'État et renforcer l'État c'est à dire
qu'il n'a pas le droit de recourir à des
prestations de conseils je pense que ça
serait une mauvaise position et une vue
un peu populiste que de dire ça c'est
parfois nécessaire mais renforcer l'état
oui c'est renforcer le cadre de contrôle
de recours à ces organismes assez
cabinets de conseils en l'occurrence on
a renforcé l'accord-cadre qui permet au
gouvernement d'encadrer justement à ça
nous l'ont fait dès le mois de juillet
on a pris des engagements pour publier
l'ensemble des commandes de l'État nous
allons les mettre dans un document
budgétaire donc je peux vous dire que je
déposerai un amendement dans le projet
de finances pour que ça soit un document
pérenne qui chaque année soit une annexe
du débat budgétaire ça donnera toute la
transparence sur les commandes voilà
pour le l'engagement du gouvernement et
du MI j'appelle Quentin Calmet à nous
rejoindre qui est notre spécialiste
cabinet de conseil à la rédaction pourra
signer un documentaire sur ce thème à la
suite des travaux de des sénateurs ce
qu'on vient d'entendre ça ne suffit pas
très clairement dernier épisode en date
c'est cette nuit pendant l'examen du
budget voilà exactement elle est
sénateurs n'ont pas l'intention de la
chair à faire effectivement dans ce
dossier c'était vers 1h du matin à la
nuit dernière quand ils ont adopté un
amendement au projet de loi de finance
l'idée pour eux et de forcer la main au
gouvernement pour plus de transparence
l'exécutif devra publier l'ensemble des
prestations de conseils privés dans un
rapport indexé au projet de loi de
finance et ce chaque année jusqu'à
présent le gouvernement vous venez de
l'entendre il voulait bien faire la
transparence sur une partie des recours
mais pas la totale transparence l'idée
pour les sénateurs c'est bien de lutter
contre l'opacité de ce recours aux
entreprises privées par l'administration
et les ministères c'était d'ailleurs
l'une des recommandations lorsqu'ils
avaient rendu leur rapport après
effectivement l'heure et quatre mois
d'enquête l'hiver dernier écoutez donc
en séance la nuit dernière il y a la SSI
qui était la rapporteur de cette
commission d'enquête elle fait référence
aussi au communiqué du parquet national
financier qui pour rappel à annoncer il
y a dix jours que ce sont au total trois
enquêtes qui sont en cours à propos des
cabinets de conseils écoutaient la suite
l'affaire McKinsey est l'ouverture des
enquêtes du parc national financier des
montres que la transparence des cabinets
de conseils n'est pas une option c'est
une nécessité alors certes le
gouvernement a publié un premier jaune
en octobre dernier ce document est
toutefois très insatisfaisant car il ne
contient aucune liste de prestations qui
aujourd'hui pourrait me dire quel
cabinet de conseil travaille pour l'État
pour quelle mission et pour quel montant
la réponse est simple personne et c'est
un problème le gouvernement qui ne veut
pas de cette transparence totale instant
encore le cas hier cet amendement a été
voté contre la vie du gouvernement parce
que le gouvernement estime avoir déjà
fait un pas en publiant ce fameux jaune
budgétaire ce document financier mais ce
document on le rappelle il n'est pas
assez complet selon les sénateurs qui
ont adopté cette nuit leur propre
amendement l'a fait des cabinets de
conseils un caillou dans la chaussure du
gouvernement en particulier quand il met
un pas au Sénat merci Quentin on peut
aussi dire un sparadra pour Emmanuel
Macron puisque le parc Anna national
financier a ouvert je vous rappelle deux
enquêtes sur le financement des
campagnes présidentielles
d'Emmanuel Macron peut-être avec vous
leur à 20 pour commencer est-ce que on
vous commencez vous dans les enquêtes
d'opinion à voir un effet de de ce
dossier on va dire McKinsey ou cabinet
de conseils sur la popularité du
président de la République cette
question c'est que pendant un moment
effectivement c'était pas un sujet de
préoccupation de l'opinion on se
souvient pendant la campagne
effectivement d'ailleurs Emmanuel Macron
avait balayé d'un revers de la main les
les interventions sur ce sujet là et
c'est vrai que dans les discussions des
français qu'on écoute bon ça c'est pas
du tout parti des des sujets
prioritaires mais ça entretient quand
même malgré tout une musique de fond sur
et ça entretient aussi défiance des
Français à les garder politique à
l'égard des élites etc et un peu de ce
monde à part qui finalement
copine alors moi je me souviens quand
j'étais étudiante un film pas vu Patrick
m'avait beaucoup marqué non mais c'est
vrai sur la collusion des médias avec
les hommes politiques et ben là c'est un
petit peu dans la même veine Pierre Karl
voilà c'était la en tout cas la grande
révélation pour nous étudions à cette
époque là et là aujourd'hui bah c'est
pareil ça entretient globalement ce
sentiment effectivement que il n'y a pas
de transparence il n'y a pas forcément
de de grands honnêteté et puis on le
voit dans la cote de confiance de
d'Emmanuel Macron là qu'on vient de
sortir la semaine dernière effectivement
il baisse deux trois points alors qu'il
était plutôt stable jusqu'à présent là
il enregistre une baisse je pense quand
même malgré tout que il y a un petit
effet aujourd'hui en disant quand même
ça commence à faire beaucoup Pablo
Pillot vient se fait appel à vos
souvenirs parce que vous allez
travailler pour pour un cabinet de
conseil qu'est-ce que vous retenez de
cette expérience non mais genre moi j'en
retiens que des bonnes choses mais j'ai
vu en fait à quel point on avait le
pouvoir en fait d'influence d'un cabinet
de conseil et important après il faut
quand même dissocier deux types de
missions en fait que remplissent ces
cabinets de conseils en stratégie la
première mission est là c'est un peu
compliqué de leur jeter véritablement la
pierre c'est par exemple je sais pas
vous avez un pour gérer vos systèmes
informatiques et bien il y a pas les
compétences dans le ministère et vous
utilisez c'est toujours l'argument que
donne de le gouvernement
c'est un gros paquet mais par contre
c'est vrai qu'on pourrait internaliser
en ce type de compétences et former des
fonctionnaires pour gérer les services
informatiques mais moi ce qui me pose
plus problème c'est quand vous posez la
question par exemple le bah qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de la Poste vous posez ça
comme question à un cabinet de conseil
et là bah il vous pond un powerpoint de
à peu près de 250 slides et puis il vous
dit bon bah voilà nous on a comme idée
la poste ça peut faire ça ça peut faire
ça il fait un audit il va voir dans
toutes les branches de la Poste La
Banque Postale les facteurs etc le seul
problème
exactement parce que c'est ça le
problème le problème il y a une vision
politique derrière et le problème c'est
la grille de lecture qui est utilisé ces
cabinets de stratégie ils ont été faits
non pas pour pour aider les États à la
base mais pour il travaille le plus
souvent avec des entreprises et donc du
coup ils ont une grille de lecture moi
j'appelle ça capitaliste eux ils
appellent ça genre manager c'est pas un
gros mot mais c'est dit mais le problème
c'est que l'État et les services publics
on peut pas les gérer comme des
entreprises vous prenez je prends juste
un tout petit exemple c'est très vite
vous prenez les facteurs voilà on reste
dans la Poste vous prenez un facteur un
facteur en gros vous pouvez le juger
vous pouvez le mettre dans un tableau
Excel et dire bon bah tel facteur à tel
bureau de poste il a distribué tant de
lettres par jour il distribue tant de
lettres par jour ça c'est la façon dont
le cabinet de conseil va vous dire si un
facteur est utile ou pas le seul
problème c'est qu'un facteur il fait pas
que ça et normalement lorsque vous avez
la vocation du service public comme on
disait avant et quand vous savez ce que
c'est qu'un fonctionnaire ben en fait il
est aussi là pour aller parler aux gens
pour aller parler aux petits vieux qui
sont isolés etc et tout ça bah le
cabinet de conseil il pourra pas le
rentrer dans son tableau Excel et donc
bah celui qui qui fera qui il faudra que
100 lettres au lieu de 200 et bah il
dira celui-là on peut fermer le bureau
de poste et bah ça ça va pas allez
Jean-Sébastien un mot rapide le débat
est censé être terminé je voudrais
savoir ce que vous pensez de cette de
cette affaire moi je disparate Emmanuel
Macron il y a cet aspect là et puis il y
a effectivement la place de de ses
cabinets de conseils pour pour aider la
fonction publique et peut-être l'image
des fonctionnaires dans l'esprit des des
ministres ou des gouvernements ça c'est
intéressant aussi oui parce que ça
rentre à un moment où la puissance
perdue la puissance publique pardon est
perçue comme en perdition justement
parce que en soi avoir recours avec les
cabinets de conseil pourquoi pas c'est
pas le point le point c'est le contrôle
effectivement on l'a vu et le rapport du
Sénat l'avait montré certains travaux
livrés par les cabinets de conseil était
absolument inintéressant et on payait
quand même peut-être même personne ne
les avait-il lu et ça ne posait pas de
problème il y a la transparence mais de
manière générale la transparence sur la
dépense publique que ce soit des
commandes faites au cabinet de conseil
ou non et puis il y a l'organisation de
l'État parce que pourquoi est-ce qu'on
fait recours à des cabinets de conseils
vous parliez de l'informatique mais
regard tous les grands projets
informatiques dans lequel se lancent
l'état aboutissent à des catastrophes
les logiciels de paiement au ministère
de la Défense au ministère quand vous le
ministère intérieur commande un logiciel
pour essayer de faire travailler
ensemble toutes ces bases ça n'aboutit
pas et non seulement c'est un aboutit
pas mais les cabinets de conseils ou les
développeurs extérieurs en question
jettent les plonge et l'État n'a même
pas pensé dans ses contrats à négocier
une Claus qui fait que ce ne soit pas
payé si le travail final n'est pas livré
donc il y a une vraie réflexion à avoir
sur l'organisation de l'État en soi et
encore plus quand on le voit aujourd'hui
tout est en train de péter de partout
mais ce sera le dernier mot pourquoi pas
après tout non
mais en hôpitaux
publics et sur les différents services
publics donc je ne peux qu'abonder dans
votre sens merci à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce